[MUSIC PLAYING]
REBECCA REIZNER: Hi, I'm
Rebecca Reizner with Google
from the Mountain View office.
I'm here at Epcot
in Orlando, Florida,
to show Tech Sassy Girlz
some interesting things
about coding.
ASHLEY SMITH: We wanted to
bring in a group of girls
and really teach them the
beginning of the app experience
all the way to this is
how you build an app,
and here's how
you begin to code.
JACKIE LAU: You're
going to help Pegman
navigate to different
parts of the world.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: We had to
program this little person
to go to different
destinations, and you
had to put things on a loop.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Now he has
to get to his destination,
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: OK.
OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER 4: Oh, I
forgot to move forward.
JAMES MCGILL: At Google,
we love creativity,
and we love passion.
My Disney Experience
app is a great example
of what you can do with a
little bit of creativity
to make sure that the
visitors to the parks
have all the information that
they need at their fingertips.
DAN SOTO: On the My
Disney Experience app,
you have the ability to
plan all types of things
with your vacation.
You could make
FastPass+ selections.
MALE SPEAKER 1: The
MagicBand, think about it
as kind of like a license plate
on a car-- context awareness,
knowing a guest
as an individual.
ASHLEY SMITH: Women
are underrepresented
in engineering, science,
math, and technology,
so we want to teach them
that technology is cool.
It's fun.
FEMALE SPEAKER 5: I think it's
good because when I get older,
it can become a good career.
FEMALE SPEAKER 6:
When I get older,
I plan on being an engineer.
I'm leaning towards aerospace
because that's my passion.
DAN SOTO: Here at Disney, we
love to celebrate moments,
and today we're also
here to celebrate
your passion for science,
technology, engineering, math.
FEMALE SPEAKER 7:
Not many people
get to experience what
we experienced today.
[CHEERS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]